johnny depp heading back to court just
weeks after his trial victory against
ex-wife amber hurt do you find that mr
depp has proven all the elements of
defamation
answer yes
here's what we know in court docs
obtained by e.t johnny faces a civil
lawsuit for assault following an alleged
physical altercation on the set of his
movie city of lies
you want a name
originally filed in 2018 the suit
alleges johnny assaulted the film's
location manager greg brooks who claims
the actor punched him twice in his rib
cage on set and johnny's own bodyguards
were forced to remove him from the scene
at one time i actually believed that
in the legal docks brooks says he
suffered emotional and psychological
injuries in the aftermath the trial is
set to begin on july 25th in los angeles
and johnny's legal team will have a
familiar face who is the real monster in
this relationship miss heard camille
vasquez who famously represented johnny
in his defamation case against amber is
listed as his attorney in the upcoming
trial
hi everyone
today's verdict confirms what we have
said from the beginning camille became a
celebrity in her own right during the
trial after she cross-examined amber he
promised you you would never see his
eyes again isn't that true
ultimately the jury decided amber did
indeed defame the actor awarding johnny
15 million dollars in both punitive and
compensatory damages we are grateful so
grateful to the jury for their careful
celebration
to the judge and the court staff who
have devoted an enormous amount of time
and resources towards this case and
while johnny is yet to do any on-camera
interviews camille and fellow depp
attorney benjamin chu went on a press
tour following the verdict i was
speaking with another friend of ours a
mutual friend of johnny's and ours and
he said i haven't seen johnny smile like
that in six years the weight of the
world is off of his shoulders he's got
his life back but they're not the only
ones speaking out amber herself is
sitting down to tell her side of the
story
how could they
make a judgment how could they not come
to that conclusion they had sat
in those seats
and heard through over three weeks
of non-stop relentless testimony
the multi-part interview will air across
the today show on tuesday and wednesday
in the promo amber gets emotional but
says she doesn't blame the jury for the
verdict i don't blame them i actually
understand he's a beloved character
and people feel they know him he's a
fantastic actor meanwhile e.t is
learning new details about the actress's
decision to open up following the trial
a source explains she was advised by her
team to lay low and take time for
herself for a couple weeks she is
feeling more optimistic now she is
confident that her side will come out
eventually looking to the future the
source adds that amber has a planned
strategy to make a comeback over the
next year
[Music]